So Joe Rogan experience podcast.
One 30 what?
What is it?
No one 30 29 I don't know.
I don't know what John Diaz,
ladies and gentlemen,
the one,
the only math later Julie Diaz came here.
He got stuck in traffic and he came here.
I'll worked up and angry.
And when Joey Diaz is angry,
it doesn't matter how much we do.
You give him,
it ain't gonna fucking come this week to socks.
This is what's going on.
Joey D as a starting this new thing on youtube called mad flavors world.
And what is the,
um,
the youtube channel,
what is it?
That flavor world.
youtube.com or something like that.
Flavor.
Mad Flavor world on youtube and it's all just videos and Joe Diaz going about
his day.
Let them bitches know.
Is this the video over the traffic one screen?
Look how bad I am.
I can't deal with this shit at seven 30 at night.
Oh fuck around though.
Hello everybody.
I'm here with my friend are we should fear.
Hi Guys.
I'm always fair.
That is just referencing our,
the spirit just got back from a tour of Canada the whole month.
Ottawa,
I saw black keys.
Did you see Blackie's lines?
They delayed for like an hour because the rain is okay.
Did you see that thing with the um,
the stage Phil?
No.
They just have this thing in Ottawa.
The week after I fell and cheap trick.
The whole stage just collapsed.
It was that same stage of shut it down for an hour.
A bunch of people left,
but I wasn't gonna fucking leave.
And they came on an hour late and played for like wait over curfew.
Wow.
How many people were left still?
How many people stay?
I'd say probably 60 70% of them.
Wow.
And it's just pulling it out on stage the next day.
I was like,
how many guys left for the black?
He's thinking it was canceled and people,
they class might kill yourself.
Kill yourself.
The black keys.
And one of my favorite new bands,
man,
they're fucking amazing.
They're amazing.
They're sold throwback.
She know.
What about with cars?
Like,
I love a fucking car.
We heal real engine.
You're fucking bar.
That's a black users harmonics to it as a sound to it.
It's just like,
it's a real fucking analog music man.
It's real music.
Just two guys,
really.
Just two people here or there.
There's so bad ass.
It's sad.
But at the end of the festival,
uh,
Jeff Ross,
Brandon's with the lead singer from the flaming lips just randomly in the street
and then knew each other and bond a room and he's like,
you should come to my insurance tomorrow and we're going to leave.
We're just stash a day and just fucking see this concert backstage.
It was the best concert I've ever been to.
It was all love and beautiful lights and colors and it was so fucking gray
called the flaming lips.
Flaming Lips.
Yeah.
What kind of music is it?
Yeah,
no,
that song,
they don't buy Jelly Harley's easy,
like 10 Jermaine's.
Wow.
It's all rock.
I guess open.
They've been around for 20 years.
That's almost 17 years ago.
That's when that came out and it's just so fucking awesome.
I was bawling like three or four times.
Not on anything.
Yeah,
you're crying.
It was so beautiful
at this fucking guy,
or hey,
don't be afraid.
Becoming a very different personal,
maybe it's much you're,
you're very different person.
When I met you,
you're
much more thankful.
I just talking about energy and Karma and you used to think it was all horse
shit,
but you've,
uh,
you've kind of changed your tune and all that and you're like,
the idea that other people's experiences in life might be true even if it's not
from it.
Hmm.
Is that what it is?
There's a lot of that.
And also like,
you know,
other things are out there.
I started seeing it.
Sometimes there's just like,
it's easy.
You can be,
you can,
you can cut somebody off in traffic and not let him in.
That's my thing.
Like,
Oh,
I fucked that guy over.
Or it's almost harder to fucking fit somebody in sometimes.
And you're like,
all right,
I could do,
I could fuck you over.
But what does that good?
But that doesn't make me feel good.
It makes you feel good to let people in it.
Yeah,
sure.
If you feel good to see this fucking wedding.
I'm not even into marriages,
but they had his wedding onstage,
live onstage,
and I got the lead singer,
Wayne Coyne.
He's just so fucking into it.
He's like by the power of the flaming lips and I got to husband and wife and
then I got really married right afterwards.
They got just as a piece right there.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
Yeah,
and he's fucking loving it and watching it.
Then he gets this idea to go get the heads is one of those guns that shoot off
confetti,
so he goes and runs behind him waiting for them to get married and the shoots it
off and wow.
This guy,
after it gets finished playing an hour and a half,
I'm sorry,
I just,
I'm changed by this fucker concert.
Really people,
these girls dancing and like Dorothy outfits and these boys dancing in a
scarecrow tin man.
Lion affects just sort of dancing and having fun.
US both sides of the stage.
Afterwards they get out of their costumes,
take that.
I write about clothes.
These are people he picks up from the audience.
Right.
He talks to each one of them signs a teacher.
We're going to talk to each stuff for like 10 minutes.
He spent another hour and a half to two hours just talking these people who
helped him out by dancing onstage.
Oh that's cool.
And it says like,
thanks guys,
have a good night.
Which anyone would do right.
It's just,
I don't know.
I'm going to see them every time they're here.
It's an amazing concert.
That's cool man.
What,
what is,
what turns you around and made you this real super positive person?
Cause you depression was a lot of it.
Really good depression.
Now that helps a lot because just sort of sitting like,
what's gonna make me happy?
I don't care about things I'm supposed to care about.
It's just like,
what's going to make me feel good right now?
We'll talking somebody overdosing.
It's hard being a comedian man.
Um,
in,
in that sense that you,
you know,
you,
you kind of are on your own.
You know,
you're kind of making your own destiny and you kind of,
you know,
you don't have to think and behave the way everybody in the office does cause
there is no fucking office.
You're kind of out there trying to sort out what is,
what is acceptable because so many of what,
so much of what we think of as acceptable,
it's just patterns.
Everybody just follows the pattern.
That's what's supposed to make you happy.
You have a beer at the ballgame that doesn't make you happy while you're fuck
good luck.
But yeah,
we'll do something else that makes you happy.
So,
so yeah,
they have no idea what the rest made you just really focus on what the fuck it
is that I like,
not what everybody wants me to like,
but what do I like?
And it's like if someone's going to think I'm an asshole for doing this,
somebody's going to think I'm weak for doing whatever it is.
Like that's cool.
I don't care.
I just care about making me happy.
They used to even joke around about on stage about being a terrible person and I
was like,
I don't like that job because you're not a terrible person.
I used to say like you're just kind of playing it up to make it seem,
make more sense to stay a joke.
It's terrible person.
Some of it too was like,
I feel like a terrible person when I do these few things because I'm a good
person so I feel horrible about a few things you might do.
Right.
But even then terrible things.
They were never terrible things.
It was,
it was just a sort of a method to get to the list to call yourself a terrible
person,
but you gotta always be careful about that audience.
People go to have a good time.
They don't want to think they're having a good time with this terrible
conscious,
just dealing as fucking evil venom.
So it was great photos and then my thrive.
Why closing in on me man,
I'm trying to thing I know it's fucking mad cause
beautiful things about the podcasts that we have with Dunkin is,
well even if we cover the same ground we,
it's always differently.
Never run out of shit to talk about.
There's always something,
you know there's always something to talk about.
Yeah,
totally man.
I'd always get as it goes to crazy places and that never happens anywhere else.
Yeah,
and you know there's something that went on today that I have been meaning to
tell you,
but I never brought it up to you before and how much you've evolved since you've
had like this real serious relationship now.
It's really interesting.
It's really interesting because like he like,
you know,
when you're around a person and they're in this constant state of turmoil and
doubt and then all of a sudden a big chunk of their life,
you know,
who you spend your time with,
who's your,
your love interest,
who is,
who's your confidant and I'll send,
and that's been established and the good way,
it's like you're so free and all these other areas,
you're free to look at things a little more discerning eye.
Right.
You know,
and you have really found your voice I think in,
you know,
since that it's real interesting.
Thanks man.
That's really cool.
It's really interesting to watch.
I mean,
because I mean we've been friends for a long time and like,
you know,
everybody has relationship issues,
but you were overage critically disturbed by them.
Like you would have them and you could sell it.
You could tell it was just like crushing.
You just couldn't,
you know,
so it was,
it's so hard to get over and then see the big picture.
You know when,
especially when you know someone breaks up with you or you know you thought it
was going to work out in,
that falls apart.
You blame yourself.
It's like fuck so hard to like come into your own.
If you're alone,
you know that's true,
but you aren't from that staff man.
It's good to get completely disintegrated from time to time.
Sure.
And then by the time you actually find someone that you really truly are
compatible with,
you have a character,
you've gone through a bunch of different things and you understand the cause and
effect.
You understand the early warning signs.
You don't understand.
You know when,
when the relationship going on,
what am I being a deck?
Am I trying to push her away because I don't want to hang out with her anymore?
What's really going on here?
You know you,
once you get through that man,
it's very interesting but you've,
you,
you will always hilarious but you've really come into your own.
I'll be like these last three years.
Thanks man.
So really cool to watch.
She actually broke out this morning.
[inaudible]
if you guys kill yourself,
they say pills.
Yeah,
I've heard that I say or electric fence either or both.
It was a guy who just passed away.
His name is Sean Thompson's,
who's a really nice car man.
Jose,
a kickboxing training for a lot of fives.
Real wild dude.
Real Fun guy from Canada boss route and discipling a 37 years old man.
Just die and asleep.
How never worked on a heart attack.
Supposedly that's the latest information.
Clogged artery or something.
Who knows?
You know,
it could be some congenital thing that you just didn't know.
He wasn't aware of it.
I'm really crazy.
But uh,
he was a great guy.
So a rusted piece.
Sean,
are we rolling?
Ladies and gentlemen.
I'm here with Neal.
Brent and I just got done doing the pop Kia.
I've known Neil for a long time.
Long ago.
Uh,
she had 92 to 90 men at the Boston Comedy Club and uh,
pretty no one.
I only used to think about you that you would be a good action moving here.
I really did.
I don't like when I didn't see you for awhile.
Like between the Boston and new,
even when you were on news,
Raina was,
he could always reminding me of Bruce Willis,
but I feel like,
uh,
they,
um,
wait,
look,
you want a different balding with bad relationship choices.
Yeah.
Uh,
um,
but,
uh,
yeah,
I always felt like we could've been in action guys that I saw that I thought he
could be something and you didn't become that.
I don't know what that means,
but I have pretty good instincts about like,
I think he could be like a thing.
And then you,
you betrayed me.
I'm very sorry.
Um,
yeah.
I would've never thought it would become a sports broadcaster.
That's the weirdest one.
Yeah.
No,
I never saw coming.
Did you ever go in for,
did anyone ever consider you for an action movie?
Did you ever do like
it's shitty one and to have a meeting with people when they were doing,
they were looking for the next Steven Seagal and Steven scope became famous.
This is before I had done anything and I was living in New York and I went in
for this meeting and the guy was just like Super Douchey,
like his attitude about martial arts.
I just remember thinking I wanted to kick his ass.
It was just really Dickey and it's like,
like so tell me why should we be like you?
Literally it was like,
well it was high blood moon,
so tell me why should we tell him with you?
I go,
wow,
is that really how we do this?
This is what really what?
I said like that's really how you talk.
You kick back and he goes,
so tell me how should we do a move with you?
Why should we do a movie with you?
Tell me and it kicks back.
Crosses his legs.
Like
cause they think it's going to be,
they think it's going to be like a story.
He came in and I said
Trump is fucking things.
Exactly.
No,
and we knew he was their guy.
He was a Douche bag.
I kept saying that it what I don't like about movies when someone does something
absolutely ridiculous.
When a guy like runs a jumps and kicks two guys at the same time we had,
we talked about this last time we were here.
That's why you a very short action movies.
Yeah.
You make very short,
realistic action movies.
That would be my actual movie.
Headbutt slammed to the balls from the ground.
STOMP has had
very little time.
There's no exchanging blows quick.
Nobody waits like Batman for that for one fight to end.
They jump on you and kill you and then there's no one.
My podcast,
the champs,
we talked about how we would,
how we have three,
my three guys that I dealt with,
the two guys had to do with how we would take Blake Griffin,
the three of you together and my move was going to be,
I'd fight his love handle,
which is really painful and it was my brother one time.
You think that stopped them?
Uh,
now he said he would just punch me.
Yeah.
Even that wouldn't stop.
You cannot hurt someone so much for the bite to love handle.
He's going to kill them.
I'm in real trouble.
Yeah.
I would say don't do that.
If you bit me,
I would,
I would kill you for sure because I know you'd be capable of doing something
really naughty like biting me.
I don't have to kill you.
Why wouldn't you just bite ball balls to,
why would you go as,
I ain't no bitch man.
But yeah,
you can really fuck someone's balls up through the pants.
When I think of my,
yeah,
but by the time you get down there,
I'm not gonna just let you buy my,
Paul's going to move out of the way.
It's going to take you a while to secure a ball biding position.
You've got to find it.
Hey is that shaft and I would have that chat and you bite of shaft.
I've learned a thing or two along the way and I'm going to implement them and on
you while you're trying to find my cock and balls of my cock and balls.
I would say no.
So that is a thing that people do though.
Sit around thinking like,
wow,
how would I do it?
This guy was going to come after me.
Brian has a very unique move to avoid rape in prison where he pretends these
kind of blow the guy and then he just pulls his dick off.
Just take that ball and stick your finger nails in and run.
That's going to work.
Right.
It will work once.
I don't even need to work on.
If you've got a guy with a big meaty cock,
you really thinking,
you pull that cap off with one yank calendar.
One of those guys who I actually believe if he believes something enough he
could make it so you know what I mean?
Like he could believe he's like,
uh yeah.
You could pull a car like he,
if any.
If I had to bet that any one person could pull a cock off of a dude,
a hard an erect cock at that,
it would be calories.
You could do it.
I just believe because we don't believe it,
if he got a bully,
you don't live in Collin Wood is so delusional.
Just as a person that I agree with balloon.
I know Brian Count enough to know that even if he believed that he could pull
the cock off,
he could not pull the cock on it.
So I know that you would believe that he could do it.
And I would sit there and go,
I hear Ya.
And I would stand there and go,
he's not gonna be able to pull the car off and he won't be able to pull the car
off.
He'll grab it,
he'll believe to yank on it.
It's hard as fuck man.
It's hard to pull it deck off.
Blake Griffin,
dude.
How big is Blake Griffin?
He's huge and his hands are like 20 to 40 to 50 something like that.
He might be able to,
it's a little Chinese deck but it looks like set a big the cockiest size,
you know,
cause it's like,
I feel like the bigger it would be easier could you get torque?
Irrelevant.
So much tendons and ligaments and stick around.
It's connected in more parts,
more cells are connected.
I mean,
I'm sure a soft Dick is probably easier to rip off in a heart deck.
Right.
Cause you could rip it more.
There's more ripping motion where you could dig your nails and just rip the
whole around your fingers.
It's not elbow skin,
it's soft skin.
So I wonder a time talking on the podcast and then
you probably can do it.
I'm a real strong guy.
Mario has put you announced that you could probably put your cock off.
You know,
we as the strong man guy,
he's like,
yeah,
it tastes like fun goals.
Like big stone balls.
Yeah,
that guy could probably pull your cock off that guy.
Um,
but Brian,
I don't know if you can pull someone's Cock off count.
Let's find out
on
one of the funniest podcast we've ever done.
Everyone I've done that was pretty darn.
I've never laughed that hard.
And I gotta be honest with you.
MVP award goes to private Brian.
He made me laugh so fucking hard today.
I want,
I told Brian we should do the lines,
uh,
needs
a pony friends that he's,
and it was even funnier because it was a contrast to the pony pony and aids set
at the same time.
It's almost like someone layer cake.
Oh,
the chocolate,
the cream
watching her.
But people
has a lot to do with it,
so where people enjoy it because right on the message board right away and
people were saying as one of the best podcasts ever,
this is the first time ever that the podcast is reached,
number one.
Out of all the podcasts on Itunes,
they're the most downloaded podcast.
It was this week was Neal Brennan and that,
that's amazing.
Thank you very much.
I'm glad everybody's enjoying it.
And a,
I predict this one will be even
funny and a bigger boy
got knocked out by it.
Illegal kick.
Hi,
I'm here with a chart.
This is one of the late podcasts.
We should have drank coffee.
I was falling asleep during this one.
Hey,
lights on.
He had to talk to Ms. Dot.
Zoey shows up in your leg going through show get.
How can they,
how can people follow you on Twitter as seem or becoming Steve Murphy comedy
comedy on Twitter all day.
All night.
All Day.
One night.
And what does the name of this movie that you're working on right now?
They made a movie.
I'm working on right now.
It's called pimps again,
it's about pimps being slaves.
It's a slasher movie,
but it's also a commonly,
and when you see,
you remember who wrote it?
It's a funny mood.
The citizen Kane of pimp.
Slash pimp.
Slash.
Movie.
When we tested it,
some positive for PCP and I was like,
well
that's not my straw,
but I can almost guarantee you that there's nothing like that on it is going to
have,
you know,
it's like if I had to guess what that Charles Port,
it's true packet,
we'd into a joint.
And the dude was like,
oh,
okay.
And he was pieces together.
He was fishing me out in front of a piece of meat on that Straw,
but he could not fucking figure out for the life of him what a straw was doing
it a container or ground up weed.
He's like,
is this fat Moron snorting weed?
He was like,
is he starting week?
So he put me to the test going like,
we found a piece of crap.
I was like,
no,
no.
It's for this instead.
Although that's,
I'm not sure,
but I think that's what it's for.
I was in that pen,
I was in the holding cell for maybe like an hour and a half.
They were really nice.
It was Canada.
I was like right in here in Montreal.
I was on my way to go to just for last last.
So they'd probably get just as scary.
No,
they did.
The dude who came,
like they pulled the bus,
you know,
are going through customs and they come to the door and it was man,
and there were two drivers with me cause we had to double time to get to
Montreal,
Clovis and Thomas.
And so,
uh,
they open the front door and as soon as the door opens,
they smelled weed.
I didn't have the fucking blowers on the bus at that point.
And they're just like,
whoa,
smells like dope in here.
And I said,
well,
there was a lot,
but not anymore.
I smoked it obviously before we come here and why bring sand to the beach
literally?
And the guy goes,
get off the bus.
I didn't know it'd be a big deal and shit.
So I was in a bathroom,
I didn't think it through,
is it a bathroom?
And I,
my slippers on cause I had just been sleeping and they took us inside and they
took the bus apart,
went through it,
whatnot.
And there was no weed on the bus froze.
I know somebody that,
well I'll get to that.
They can come into the into,
I'm sitting in the,
in the lobby or station,
whatever,
fuck the check point.
And then I hear a door open,
somebody come in and guys like,
uh,
could you stand up please sir?
And as the dude,
the same guy who was like get off the bus and they're wearing the heavy duty
fast and they've got a border patrol and shit,
I'm fucking around.
Could you just stand up please?
And I said,
me.
I said,
yeah,
cause you signed up.
And I stood up.
He goes,
cause he's turned face the window,
Sarah,
at this point I'm like,
I'm like,
am I getting a breast?
And it turned to face the window.
He's like,
put your hand behind your back knowing I felt the bracelets clamp on and shit.
And now he's like,
we're arresting you for suspicion of a narcotic assumption chef,
or what it was.
It was like,
he took me over to a holding cell like that was literally from here to where
that picture is.
And then he goes,
okay.
And he took my cuffs off to go from fucking 10 feet and put the cuffs on me,
put me into this right before he put me in this out,
then took her cuffs off and I sat in that room and shit.
And I was like,
oh my God,
this is it.
My life's over.
I don't know what's going on.
And they're very polite,
very cool.
You know,
they kept bringing me water and they were like,
we don't want a donut.
And I was like,
I do,
but not right now.
I don't eat.
I was sweating bullets and like the word,
like,
God,
I was born in road,
the south and what?
Um,
and then I,
I still gave me a phone call,
call my word,
said,
hold on.
And then he called like as Toronto fucking border or somebody or something
because we were much of near Montreal.
And the dude got on the phone with them and then you get on the phone with me,
they would take me from myself to the rooms of a phone call or whatever.
And uh,
he was like,
ah,
look,
they're not going to charge your phone call.
I think he gets to go again.
It doesn't happen.
I mean that was,
I've never done it before,
but it's the one time,
but I called thank colors during business hours and my lawyers,
my lawyer threw me to,
uh,
Toronto lawyer who is the slack squashed.
Don't worry about,
it's gone.
A number one,
there's under whatever it was like this is enough for maybe two joints or
something.
So right then and there they'll like come on a number two cause they didn't look
for that.
They're looking for bricks.
Somebody's Willie they're looking for,
yeah,
that would come across her stuff or something like that.
So they said that's that number two,
they said,
um,
we can't like,
it's on the bus,
we don't know that it's yours.
So the citation is written to the bus and my bus cut charged with possession of
whatever under a minor amounts,
whatever,
whatever is under under announced way under an ounce or something like that.
And a,
they wrote the boss a ticket when I was copacetic too.
Powerful video.
It was weird though.
But the dude like a,
they were very nice.
Like the,
there were some cats who was
I,
it was leaked.
That was on the bus left on the bus.
We were previous chip.
Somebody went and hid poison or some coat jacket,
uh,
in on a boss,
like wipe my wife's Kojak and his jacket.
She hadn't worn in ages and stuff.
And so that's where they miss your boss.
But somebody who had left it on there,
somebody else about his stash in there.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
But luckily they let me know.
Yeah.
Oh my God,
it's 10 30.
That's ridiculous.
This is the longest podcast we've ever way.
Yeah.
Why?
I mean,
I can't speak with this.
Mother fucker knows how to talk.
It's got some chicken was good.
We had,
it was wonderful.
It was funny.
A lot of fun.
It's a real conversation.
I can't wait.
What I like to do is now go home,
role a big fat joint and go read the Twitter feed for the last few hours.
Cause that that's,
that's the trip where you're just like,
oh they got it.
They're dialed in,
blah blah,
blah.
Yeah.
It's going to be cool.
It's so funny.
I love that we share that philosophy about keeping everything free too.
I guess
I shouldn't call him that.
Maybe easily offended.
Did you see that shit that's going on with Katt Williams?
Some guy that was a Mexican who was yelling in the audience and,
and Katt Williams told them that you brought a rusty knife to a gun flight 22
the your aunt Tia gave yet your,
since the era like he fucking went off on this dude and they wrote an article
about it in CNN have the,
there,
the writer was Mexican and he was offended.
Meanwhile,
I cherry picked all the information.
The guy yelled at Katt Williams fuck America and he was like,
cat when he's like,
fuck America,
Fuck America.
Did you say that?
And he comes over and he puts a fucking ego in from God bless America.
It's funny,
he was being a fucking comedian
and writer,
Mexican American writer was offended and I'm offended that you're so fucking
stupid.
I wish I remember your name,
but I don't.
But this nonsense,
this PC bullshit.
Everybody in looking to fucking find something it'd be upset with.
That's a live comedy show.
If you don't like that raw dog,
wild balls out type of comedy.
The Cat Williams does.
Don't go to the fucking show.
You should know that he does that anyway.
There's plenty of videos of him online.
He's a bad motherfucker.
If you don't,
if you don't like that,
don't go to that show.
But if you fucking go and you know what he does and you get offended,
kill yourself,
kill yourself.
You fucking the same fucking boat.
Mrs Rogan's or I come out all this yet on the screen,
but I want one
zero wizards
wizards.
Oh Ladies and gentlemen,
that's it for this.
That's it for today.
John Half Heffron in the fucking house.
If I'm on Twitter,
that's two apps.
Nephron in an nation and a no thanks Tim Ferris looking at me.
He's like a school boy.
He's kind of attack that time.
He's ready to go.
I always feel weird when I wear a backpack in the airport.
I always feel like a Dork.
There's something about a backpack like can be sleeping over one shoulder.
He kind of be like kind of casual.
Cool feel.
Just got my books.
But if you actually have it on like hey for the hostel,
the camera that is,
that's a tough looking back at it looks sort of school boy ish ten first came on
the podcast today and uh,
we talked about so much cool shit man.
That was another one where people are going to have to back up and write names
down and books down and what we'll,
what's he saying that we just covered so much shit and though the thing that
tripped me out the most was you talking about shoving that stuff up your nose
and increasing your short term memory and earned as Chinese when you were doing
the Chinese character.
That's crazy,
man.
That's nuts.
I've never heard of anything with human and machine.
That's it's a wonderful thing.
It really is man.
But you,
you really have explored a lot of the more interesting aspects of that to them.
Man.
You've got an amazing amount of information when it comes to that stuff.
So,
uh,
pick up that book folks.
A four hour body and four hour workweek or Tim's books and you can check out his
website for our blog,
for our blog,
Amazon,
obviously a couple thousand reviews so you can read the most amusing one stars.
Those are my favorites.
One Star,
one star review is a,
do not buy this book because he'll take the money to set a new Guinness record
and strangling kit.
I thought that was a secret or you've done some crazy,
it's like,
do you have a tango record?
World Tango Record,
tango spins.
And I did a thing.
It was sent 34 to 34 37 spins on and Kelly actually spends a one minute.
Yeah.
Oh that was the record.
They do it in one minute with a partner who travels around you in a diameters
but 10 12 feet.
So it takes more time than people would take.
How long did you learn how to do that?
Go into this six months in Argentina,
Florida.
Eight hours a day of tango until my feet were black on the bottom.
How old are you?
34 you've been everywhere too.
That's amazing.
How much,
how many different countries you've been to this 35 I had to count them out
because to get a visa for India,
they make you list every country had been to in the last 10 years,
even though the only thing that I want to know is are you a terrorist from
Pakistan?
So they could just ask you,
have you been to Pakistan?
But no,
they were like lifts out every country you've been in the last 10 years.
So I counted up about 35 same.
How do you have the time to do that?
That's amazing.
These days.
I ain't used to bounce around online to short trips.
I find that tiring now.
I'd just like to relocate for a few months at a time if I'm going to do it at
all.
Uh,
so we'll see.
But I like,
I do like relocating it cause like the first time I went abroad at all really it
was a year in Japan as an exchange student and I was introduced judo.
That was where I lived with a Japanese family and one I relocate like that for
me at least,
it shows me how much my behavior is just arbitrary.
Like driving on one side of the street,
uh,
let's say soaping down in a shower as opposed to before a bath.
I mean it's all just culturally reinforced and so I find it fun to look through
my life again through a fresh lens when I get back to the u s I think that's,
that's really fun.
Yeah.
It's always amazed me how different cultures are when I've only been to maybe
six or seven different countries,
but like the difference between the way people behave in Brazil as opposed to
the way they were here to Germany and I was supposed to wear it.
You know,
it says amazing man.
It's amazing how people vary and how adaptable we are to both our environment
culture.
And you just get used to certain things,
you know?
Well I remember was staying with this German family and we were watching the
Simpsons and because it's dubbed into German,
she's like,
oh the Simpsons or from the u s like I thought it was German.
Oh that's funny.
Cause they had only seen it in German on German television.
Do they,
how do they translate the jugs?
Do you speak German?
I speak uh,
pretty mediocre German get to judge Schultz.
Don't translate.
I mean,
do you know what I mean?
They just don't,
they're so subtle and they're also like these weird cultural references to,
does German efficient,
do they have any stand up in Germany?
I've never seen standup in Germany.
I've seen standup in Japan,
which is cool.
Traditional Japanese standard where they have two guys like kneeling down or
sitting on pads and there are traditional Kimonos and it's just two guys
bantering back and forth.
That standup comedy in Japan.
It's very cool.
So,
so it's all nice and Kimona.
Yeah,
they'll like do like the sort of judo,
Jujitsu style and kneeling on the feet and then they'll just sit there like a
fan and why each other on the head and do this banter back and forth.
Oh,
so they always do it with another person.
Wow.
They're still in sort of a VOD village sort of overlap.
So they do a lot of slapstick,
ton of slapstick ties.
It's weird how cultures,
like some cultures are,
you know,
it's weird how like America is so stand up comedy heavy,
know so many standup comics come.
A lot of them come from England,
a lot of them comfortable.
But you never hear about this down at talks from Germany.
You know we had one that used to come to the comedy store.
He was like famous in Germany.
He was like on a television show,
but he wanted to come to America to make it.
But everything he did was like crazy physical.
It was all like flying through the air and fall on his head.
It was all weird,
nutty shit.
Pulling stuff out of bags,
smashing it'll together and noises.
Sound effects.
It's like their sense of humors,
alien to our Q and German sense of humor is very different in the US for sure.
I mean it's still English,
English sense of humor almost relies on a higher level of politeness than we
currently enjoy.
Their whole this,
the pacing of their humor,
everything.
Replot relies on being polite.
Is there any non us place like kind of about Scotland,
Wales,
UK or Britain?
Is there anywhere outside of the u s produces consistently good Kardex or
Australia has some good ones.
Australia,
Australia has some Australia also rugged cats,
you know they have some wild dudes so Australia is like,
it's make sense of data when people are like what the fuck's going on?
And they write it and it's like,
it makes sense.
Yeah.
That they would like Jim Jefferies,
a great comic.
He's from Australia.
There's another dude,
I forget his name but real funny guys from Australia because a few,
they have like seen down there too.
We performed a Sydney,
they've got a real comedy club down there.
Yes it needs a great city.
Australia,
he's an unemployed so I live the apocalypse head.
It's a good move.
So it's out there.
It's pretty far away.
How much of a target?
Yeah.
Except crocodiles and fucking snakes and shit.
Poisonous spiders and the fact that 80% of the country's uninhabitable.
Oh,
that's true.
Yeah.
I think you can only live around the edges and the inside you'll go by people
who get killed by other animals might get killed by people you might get killed
by aboriginals.
I talked about slice gel before our blog,
[inaudible] dot com [inaudible] experience.
And then also Miss Grace,
if you would,
if you think you would ask Mary Kill Red Band,
Sam Aaa.
Do you have 50 Mary had he killed?
Like
are you serious?
Okay.
I know,
I know.
Sam would love to just brush humper he's a big fan.
Okay.
Good to know.
We are,
we are,
we are moving on.
Sorry about that.
Um,
okay,
so I apologize for that,
but it's kind of live sat with you question.
Okay.
So,
um,
so.